hi before 3 2 1 baby hello everybody
hello to another episode of a genius a
brain what's going on you beautiful
people a man um I want to bring you on
this hike would like ha ha ha so here's
the thing okay I know you're afraid of
heights yeah but it's really worth it
because by the time you get to the top
it's [ __ ] insane like there's it it
feels like a hill on a valley like sound
of music but it doesn't look like that
when you're going up there this is in LA
yeah it's in Simi Valley in it's kind of
off trail so there is a trail but it's
not an official trail what's it called
it's um I think it's called like Big Sky
or Sky Park or some [ __ ] like that I
forgot but there's a there's a dog park
there and I found it because there's a
huge dog park I'm talking like it's like
a acre oh did you take Jess with you too
yeah I thought she was scared of hi see
she's scared of heights she gets vertigo
but she challenged herself anime me just
love her even more my [ __ ]
disapproving Asian dad was so proud
because she challenged herself
oh [ __ ] that girl she's on this like tip
of improving herself as stuff makes me
feel that she's like doing [ __ ] that she
never did before stuff yeah makes me
sick but it made me so happy that I
ended up we went to REI and then I was
like I'm gonna buy you some [ __ ]
hiking shoes cuz she did it with some
regular pair of Nikes that was slipping
so she was like slipping all over the
place as hell is scary but she was like
you know if I had some hiking shoes and
I'm like oh [ __ ] yeah I'm gonna get that
and then she's like I never did anything
this like challenging before but I was
thinking about you cuz I was like
alright I know I've been hiking with you
I know how you get vertigo and you're
afraid of heights too but it's very like
manageable it's not as crazy as when we
did pill box like pill box was just or
if it's not as crazy as pill box I could
do that cuz like here's the thing though
there are parts though that that are ok
small parts very small parts because so
there was like so there's like there's
this place called Echo Mountain that I
try to do yeah and that's basically
like the roads is why does this table
yeah and if you fall you're dead okay
it's it's that it's like a steep
drop-off and I that was the first time I
ever experienced vertigo and I basically
blacked out for two seconds and that's
the part that scared the [ __ ] out of me
with like yeah and I could have died I
didn't I've never really blacked out
like that before
so what did you do go back down I
[ __ ] when I came to I was like I kind
of like was teetering yeah and I kind of
snapped out of it I was like holy [ __ ] I
freaked out I just hugged the wall and I
ran down cuz I feel like Mario would
love this Oh Mario will do Mario's crazy
she would love that she's an adventure
seeker she loves hiking that's her thing
take her dude
cuz for me this is it was it was easy
moderate but then like I'll attach a
GoPro to her chest enough
then I'll see what it's like Bart said
he would do it he said he'd do it with
Tiger I don't give a [ __ ] I know I know
but he's also afraid of heights - yeah
but Bart also did pull-ups would take a
you know fully well that's you know
weight room that [ __ ] mean yeah but
it's it's cool because like I like going
a little bit off trail because I like to
not know yeah what's gonna where I'm
going or where I'm gonna end up - yeah
and then at the top of this mountain
there's all these trees right it was
[ __ ] crazy you get up there and
someone set up a swing on the tree and
it's this it's this whole side of La
that I was never used like there's no
smog over there it's nothing but
mountains it's such a beautiful view and
then I get this feeling of like free did
you do that one hike near what's it
called Santa Monica it's kind of like
that where I've heard of that one my
Malibu ish yeah my mouth yeah I heard of
but I I didn't see I did that one where
was the clouds under you did you do that
I thought it was pretty high up there
but I did it because it was tiring his
[ __ ] but it's kind of you're like the
the path up there it's just all trees
and mountain is hell yeah when you go up
top you see everything so that's a [ __ ]
now but but I love hiking I love nature
old people shit's the [ __ ] to do now man
that's like with all the Instagram folks
do anyways they go up there they they
show their [ __ ] and they're like yeah
I climb this I have no idea what don't
know how these girls [ __ ] hike in a
thong I don't know how they do it either
man they're just wearing nothing they
were absolutely I'll tell you this
though I don't mind it
thank you thank you very much it's it's
it's nice when you're hiking in front of
me I don't know I want to go to some
secluded ass place and just [ __ ] it you
would love the hikes in Kauai though
like quiet like the the hike sort of
treacherous is [ __ ] but the views are
amazing I mean since you lost like a
good jillion pounds like hiking to you
now is it different I feel like it's
still tiring like it doesn't for example
because you know to my complex well I
thought that after I lost 60 pounds like
going up those stairs we're gonna be
easier it's not diegans [ __ ] I don't
know but but is it scary though I feel
different like you feel more confident
cuz I can control yourself more or like
now it's the hyping is always affect I
just watched this documentary about this
dude he's a Sacramento native yeah and
he free climbed no ropes no no oh my god
up what's it called El Capitan what like
like bouldering right like just no no
rope no rope no nothing it's like I
think he climbed like 3,000 feet or some
[ __ ] it took him like two hours to do it
without a rope bro without a [ __ ]
rope that means if he fell he died I
know that's it that's I think that's
what they get their adrenaline rush is
like no turning back they got to keep
going and then you kind of saw his
personality throughout this documentary
and he if he didn't find climbing he
would have been a serial killer like
it's one of those like I kid you not
it's one of those things like thank God
he found climbing because he would have
just been murdering people and cooking
their intestines for fun cuz he would
say some really just off-color [ __ ] in
terms of this he goes you know if I died
you know do people really care you don't
care life goes on even my girlfriend
like if I thought if I died she would
find somebody else and she would move on
doesn't matter
you know and that's kind of suicidal he
it's just he's definitely on some [ __ ]
were like emotional attachment it's only
for he feels it with an adrenaline rush
yeah other than that it's it's super
superficial I could kind of feel that
yeah my brother's like that
oh really yeah yeah I think what they
were saying is like a lot of CEOs
extreme sports people yeah high
achieving like athletes and [ __ ] like
that
they they had they have the same what I
don't want say symptoms but
characteristics to people that are like
oh [ __ ] like psycho yeah successful as
[ __ ] yeah because either you're like
successful businessman and artists
artists like it like there's dirt
showing like Picasso art and like a
serial killer doing art and it's like
similar oh yeah yeah the way that their
brain is wired and [ __ ] like that do I
just had this conversation where I'm
saying like the craziest people are the
most successful men like all these like
actors a [ __ ] Jim Carrey is insane
but did you see his artwork and his body
of work as an actor in a comedian yeah
the [ __ ] man but I don't want to be like
him own he even said that like I wish
everybody was rich and famous so they
know how it it doesn't mean anything
yeah like I mean like that's [ __ ]
profound because everyone wants to be
rich and famous and they think that it's
gonna be better and then they become
it's like if you had the opportunity to
become become that you don't want to do
it I just want to be rich [ __ ] the fame
part man like [ __ ] the fame part man you
want to be rich without the work oh yeah
yeah that's what it is men
it's weird how much people put value
into what somebody else says gives them
value like I feel important because
people think that I'm important that's a
very sad way to live because that stuff
disappears dude even the Bema
celebrities at the highest level right
now they're not gonna feel the same type
of Fame when they popped off the very
first time and they were popular for the
first 5 or 10 years after a while they
just become a relic and if you based
your life on what other people think
about you dude it's gonna be hard man
when you start becoming quote-unquote
irrelevant as how they call it nowadays
irrelevant yeah you know what I mean
like who really [ __ ] cares man yo if
you got money and it's just coming in
you're pretty good do it yeah you now
you get to choose what your career in
life is I do know a lot of entrepreneurs
that want Fame cuz they have the money
part so they want the attention now oh
my god what are you gonna do unless
you're a bachelor and you're just trying
to just get [ __ ] 24/7 what the [ __ ]
doll actually I think it's validation oh
really I think people want to feel like
they matter mmm so like that's why I
like you know a lot of people want likes
on their come you know like it's it's
just attention like attention is an
important thing
societally like like you know I mean in
society gaining attention getting
validation knowing that you're special
things like that it we're wired to want
those things because it makes us feel
valuable in the social hierarchy world
okay yeah so like it's kind of like if
you think about like primitive time
right like like if you are you know the
guy that always catches the biggest elk
and everybody you're the talk of the
village cuz David here always catches
the elk right it's gonna make me want to
be the top dog and compete cuz I want to
be the biggest elk catcher now so so
then like because if you're the biggest
elk catcher like all the girls want you
because you get the biggest like me and
and everyone likes you I'm just the
weird one huh I mean I think it's
natural to want those things but then I
think it's like this weird sick twisted
thing yeah I don't think I'm above it
because I think III enjoyed it when I
was younger so I think everyone
everybody did yeah I'm not above that
[ __ ] like what the [ __ ] I'm I understand
but you want it through skill you so
it's different like like if you are the
top dog on the basketball team and
you're really good and then you you feel
like you deserve the fame a bit right
versus someone who's just popular
because yeah I like the validation from
like like for example the other day or
it's been happening recently actually
where a few fans have been coming up to
me saying not so much I love your stuff
but they said yo I watch your stuff and
I've been watching you since I was like
14 college now and because of you
whatever it was that I said or from the
vice videos that I gave they're like I
chose to break out of my shell
that's dumb being so shy about things
and you know just go out there and
failing and learning new things about
life instead of living in my small
bubble yeah - something I always wanted
people to do because I was that kid yeah
I was that [ __ ] I call it a loser
because I chose to to close myself off
because I was always comfortable yeah
and I just didn't want that for other
people you know especially if they
followed me and I happened about three
times in the past like couple weeks
where somebody said that and that's the
validation that I see : same here it's
where you know
they say thank you but I'm saying thank
you to you too because you're showing me
that the stuff that I did it worked you
know not just for me but for the few
people that did listen it helped them
out and that's the validation that maybe
I seek I mean that's the only reason why
I want fame is so I have attention from
people so I could open up their minds or
see life a little bit differently then
what you know like because I know a lot
of people feel trapped
they don't know how to get out of it and
in it's it's really like me speaking to
my younger self yeah it's it's kind of
selfish if you think about it it's just
me wanting like I kind of get this sense
of relief when I hear that younger
people figured it out and I wish someone
told me something yeah
so I created you know like all this art
and everything that's that I do it's
like whether it's talk shows or skits or
anything it was it came from me like
trying to figure out how to deal with
like growing up you know and in this in
this world and and the pressures of
parents and in society and relationships
and all that stuff and then I just
package it through content you know and
then people watch that and I think they
they understand what I'm trying to
communicate and then they learn from it
and they feel better from it totally
different from like you know just making
a video I want people to understand too
is that when a lot of people give advice
yeah they're not saying it in the sense
of you know I've always known better
than you most of the time it's you know
I made those same mistakes so let me
tell you something that I wish I would
have known during that time yeah so when
I say stuff like oh that's dumb don't do
that it's not because I didn't make that
mistake - yeah I'm talking to myself
yeah I'm like do man you remind me of
myself yeah the advice that I give it's
your right is selfish in part because
I'm really talking to myself yeah I'm
trying to make sure I don't make those
mistakes too and when I see that in
people that I care about I'm like yo man
I've been down there and I've done it
and I still do it to this day so to make
sure you don't do it I think that's
that's the main reason why we
immediately click because we have
similar values and what we're trying to
our content is motivated from the same
thing yeah it's motivated from
what we learned through life and
communicating that through whether it's
art or just conversation do what is like
just Kings motto in the first teaching
good things in a bad way yeah and that's
what I [ __ ] with the most men and um
when I got asked this question a lot was
you know why do you curse so much you
know don't you think that you could
reach out people if you stop cursing as
much and this is what I said to that not
everybody's you exist a lot of people
that are like where we grew up and the
way that we spoke is how I speak now
yeah just because you digest information
in that way
doesn't mean that my audience is gonna
take it that way to some people just
want it said to them the way that they
want to hear it they want to hear from
people that they relate with yeah so
teaching good things in a bad way
resonated with me too because that's
what I did
you know it's like I would say for
example like some people will come up to
somebody in a break up and they'll say
stuff like yo man like I'm sorry this
happened I you'll get through it you
know I was saying in a different way I'd
be like you'll [ __ ] that [ __ ] man let's
go drink different you know what that
means
which brings us to the topic of the day
so me and you we've been friends for
such a long time I think it's like over
eight years now has been a long time
[ __ ] dude it's hard but it was like when
we all kind of men like the friendship
just clicked it was like one of those
natural like you didn't have to pretend
or like flirt we just were friends and
we just stuck together like that but for
the longest time you know like me and
Bart we we kept the race hidden you knew
who we were like you know we did it
because for other reasons that we
explained but like recently when I did
come out and things like that and we we
do videos together I've been noticing
like there's things like oh I can't
believe David like hangs out with all
these non-koreans he's not Korean enough
or whatever Japanese evil people are
they yeah they use our people are like a
piece of [ __ ] but then you get flack for
not being Korean enough yeah we're like
I get you know like there's controversy
obviously oh why did you hide yourself
that you're Japanese were you ashamed of
that exactly between Japanese and Korean
and things like that but like we really
don't look into those stupid-ass things
yeah and you know to that man there's so
many things to talk about that like in
India
let's just start with this right I was
always taught specifically because I
grew up in a Christian household to
judge people for who they are as
individuals so your did your family kind
of tell you the the all the the
struggles they went through through the
war and stuff no no did they did they do
it like your grandparents must've right
no my grandpa my dad my grandpa was dope
dude this fool fled this [ __ ]
and the war is happening he got in a
little boat with his family went to an
island Wow
so there was a lot of Korean people that
did that because I didn't want to be a
part of the war yeah and they didn't
want to die
I see so they they they escaped off I
guess like two small islands or
something like that that's from what I
remember and there was like a like a
group of people that just did that and
waited the war out yeah cuz they were
scared they didn't want to die and
that's that's what my grandpa did and I
think my aunt was born off the coast of
some kind of small island or some [ __ ]
like that my eldest your personal your
family personally didn't go through any
tragedies due through the hands of
Japanese people maybe my mom side did
but my mom doesn't talk much about her
family no and we had relatives that did
but like I said my dad doesn't dwell in
the past
yeah and that's something that I learned
from my father a lot he doesn't dwell in
the past he understands the history he
understands what happened and what went
on yeah but he does even my grandpa
doesn't though yeah I'll put it to you
like this man my grandpa could write in
Japanese and in Chinese or whatever
Hahnemann which is like Chinese are
stuff it was taught to him at that age
and he would show me like hey look you
know I could write in Japanese and all
this other stuff wow he didn't say it
like you know [ __ ] Japanese people yeah
I hate those a [ __ ] job you know he
didn't do any of that yeah showed me
that he could do it damn and my grandpa
didn't tell me stories about hate either
yeah in my family like that I think we I
guess my family deals with it in like
that happened it was [ __ ] up but we're
gonna move on from it yeah and I think
that was the whole the Christian side of
things I mean but there are still
Christians that can't let go like it's
not just a Christian thing right it's
just I think your family knows how to
forgive yeah cuz I did have other Korean
Christian friends that they they just
they they always had to bring it up and
like I'm like I didn't do anything you
know they're gonna get into religion but
that's yeah price like yeah and then I
grew up Christian to Christian yeah yeah
but you're right like I mean I think
there's a lot of hypocrites no matter
where you go right like but my first
experience of that when I was a kid is
like my mom didn't tell me anything
about like that stuff right yeah
and they didn't deny it they just told
me like you know we Japanese people did
a really bad thing during World War two
that's what they told me as a kid yeah
and then one time my Korean friend in
elementary school was having a sleepover
but then like I wasn't allowed and then
and then oh and my friends like sorry
you can't come because you're Japanese
and I'm like why and he goes well my
grandma says she doesn't want you there
and then he was crying he was sad about
it because he didn't understand you
didn't understand I didn't understand I
was sad about it so I went home and I
told my parents about it and my parents
were like nah forgive him it's cool and
then that's when they told me the
stories about like how Japanese people
bullied everybody and you're not
everyone's gonna like you because of
that reason so I was like oh man that
really sucks because we're kids and it's
like and you have to pay for that right
and in the my friends grandma is
perpetuating it yeah I mean she probably
went through something really [ __ ] up
yeah for her to like project her hate
toward a child uh-huh but then I don't
know like I also don't can't say
anything cuz I'm like yeah I don't know
what happened I don't know what kind of
pain she went through you know and I
think like be the sad part about that is
like I don't want to transfer hate over
yeah right so for your friends grandma
rightfully so she should be angry that's
something that she went through a
hundred percent man and I can never but
she should be mad at the people that did
wrong to her yeah I'm not to the kid not
to the random kid yes born in America
and even it to that point to like I but
I still understand where she's coming
from it's so you know there's I don't
know if you people even know about this
but there were something called like
comfort women yeah you know like women
in Korea were used as sex slaves yeah
like that's awesome
Arius [ __ ] up [ __ ] you know and when I
hear about those stories it makes me
sad yeah but when I look at a Japanese
person I don't see that though yeah I
see the history that happened and this
could be from a Korean American
perspective you know what I mean but I'm
also saying this too I have relatives
and friends in Korea and they also vibe
with this same concept - yeah they
travel to Japan consistently from work
and even just from work for fun I have a
friend in Korea right now that has a
Japanese wife yeah you know what I mean
so you know for for people to come out
and say like you don't know what it's
like to be Korean no you actually just
see it in your small perspective a it
from I'm trying to see it from
everybody's perspective and yes it's
anecdotal cuz I'm saying it from my
friends in Korea that are like that
there's actually a lot of Koreans
invited yeah that are I forgot what
they're called but they were in Japan
since like throughout history there's
always been Korean immigration yeah but
they changed her name to Japanese names
but they're a hundred percent ethnically
Korean oh oh wow yeah like one of
Japan's Aretha Franklin like she's like
a soul singer from the 60s right she's
hella famous her name is Otto Waukee
whadda Akiko okay but she's a
full-blooded Korean oh really but she
has a Japanese name the founder of kill
chain karate mas oyama mm-hmm he's a
Korean full-blooded but the [ __ ] yeah
but but you know he there's a lot of
like like there's a I mean they went
through eighth Nick persecution yeah so
they changed her name to Japanese names
to blend in yeah but yeah I mean same
with the the owner of Lotte like I
always grew up thinking Lotte was a
Japanese company yeah and you you know I
was like really yeah and then what I
found out is right after World War two
he he's a Korean immigrant that came to
Japan and then he built a company in in
in developing Japan selling gums and
candy Oh which is what look these about
what's next snacks they world yeah and
then he he was here he became successful
in Japan and then he took it to Korea
after Korea's war went down yeah and
then he he built up there and then he
basically had two massive companies in
two countries Wow
but he's he's full-blooded Korean so
like a lot of people don't know that
there's a lot of like intermingling yeah
there's debt they just found out that in
the royal family of Japan there is
Korean DNA like because I don't know if
you're familiar with like Korean history
but like you know how they had the three
kingdoms Silla and whatever right but
one group or one Kingdom got taken over
by another one in Korea yeah and then
they needed to run away because they
were facing persecution so the royal
family in Japan brought them in as
refugees oh wow
but they you know but they're friends
with these Royals of Korea so they're
like well you can't live like a peasant
in here so they integrated them into the
royal family and they married them so
the the Emperor was saying like his
great great great aunt or grandfather or
whatever was a product of half Korean
half Japanese so in the royal bloodline
there's like recent I'm talking recent
like four hundred years ago yeah DNA
fresh Korean Royals that are like
blended in so it's it's pretty the
relationship there is really like close
yeah there's a lot of history even in
recent history man there's like a lot of
you know but they don't teach that [ __ ]
yeah yeah I mean if we look back far
enough there's there's their stories and
signs of positivity and negativity you
know it depending on how far you look
back you know and when I when I it's
just so odd man like I don't understand
why people want me to hate a specific
group because of something that happened
in the past they want me to dig so far
in my past not even my past and somebody
else's past that happen to them and say
hey you should hate these people because
of what they did back then that you
weren't a part of but because they did
that you should hate them even though
you never did before
yeah and I don't have that ability and
I just don't have that thing to blame
somebody for something that they didn't
do to me personally that we are trying
to move past because it stops progress
it stops healing is what it is yeah for
sure you know and it's just so weird
like you I've had comments where they're
like yo man you're so you think you're
so Korean you don't know anything about
accordion oh what a Japanese are people
then yours and make upon accordion a
people like your said quoting people
angry I kill you what do you mean you
mean the death threat doesn't really
solidify that opinion I know you know
you son of a [ __ ] like how dare you man
do you think they're Koreans from Korea
or do you think they're Korean Americans
there are definitely Koreans the ones
that I've read are like I could tell
that recent even recent immigrants are
the koreans from korea because they
don't get the context in a joke they
don't get the contest in the joke and
even the writing is involved mmm so it's
like oh you know i could tell a little
bit and some people aren't and they're
probably korean americans and they have
a lot of hate towards whatever that is
yeah any kind of like satire you make
about korean people like don't [ __ ] on
korean people you chill relax your
[ __ ] sphincter it's a joke that's
what people do we're allowed to make fun
of our culture because it's our [ __ ]
it's an inside joke you [ __ ] relax
they don't like those kind of jokes they
don't they don't they don't get it like
we'll say this like dude you don't like
roasting themselves yes they don't like
roasting it like I'm like yo man Korean
people do their [ __ ] anger like we're
not angry
I kill you what do you mean I'm not
angry I'm not kicking your ass damn like
relax man like it's a joke that's like
the create creed people because we're
passionate is [ __ ] man yeah it works on
both ways man forget it though it's like
I kind of see why Koreans have to like
really band together and like and kind
of like be aggressive cuz like yeah cuz
like Korea's been picked on a lot like
yeah China Japan everybody kind of
picked on Korea it's a new country yeah
you know like so so to build that
identity to build that no one's gonna
[ __ ] with me anymore like it's almost
like I can see how the culture can
evolve into being like I'm not gonna be
pushed around you know yeah I mean it's
it's so interesting because I love
Japanese call
command-i but it's almost like you're
not allowed to or else your backstabbing
Koreans yeah and I I like Japanese
culture just because it all started with
anime bro
you know it's I kind of feel like it's
asian-americans that perpetuate the hate
more than the people in Asia yes kpop is
hella popular in Japan Korean dramas
like there's all these old Japanese
ladies that love Korean dramas man like
and when I'm out there my mom tells me
yeah like there's no feeling of that in
Japan like amongst her and her friends
like yeah and and you know they like
they're the biggest trading partner like
Japan and Korea they do the most
business yeah so I'm like is it is it
something that like people carry on here
and then they just slide feel like some
people feel like they have to or they
feel like they're a traitor or something
you know yeah it's it's this false sense
of loyalty sometimes what I feel like I
like a date they seem like they move
past it yeah I don't know it's like an
ideal that I feel like sometimes people
feel like they happen you know I
guarantee you 5060 years from now it's
gonna be a lot easier I hope so it's
it's going to be a lot easier and I
think if you want to hold that hate in
your heart I can't tell you to change it
yeah you know but I want people to think
about it like this what does it do for
you and what does it do for the healing
process and there's a there's a big
thing I think about Japan not giving
Korea formal apology yeah and that's the
thing that I think it's like the last
thing that's really holding that healing
point because I think Japan gave a
formal apology to China but they did
well I did read some stuff about Japan
recognized and sent money to Korea hmm
about war and stuff like that but then I
don't really know the details I think
that recently the controversy is because
of the island that they're fighting oh
yeah so they're fighting over that
island I actually don't know too much
about that [ __ ] yeah I'm gonna have an
opinion about it but yeah that's like a
deadly to me but I do know that there's
other issues too like where Japan
doesn't teach about their war
crimes in the history books and a lot of
Asian countries are upset about that and
things like that
and I know there's just little things do
it either though that's true what
country does what country does what yeah
but I mean I for me it's like it's kind
of pointless cuz I can't run the I can't
change what that country does and I'm an
American at the end of the day I'm gonna
merit so I'm like well the [ __ ] sucks
that that's happening yeah and I I think
that people should figure out a way to
move past it and learn from it but not
deny it I think denying things in this
denial probably is the plant that hurts
the most yeah that's the stuff that
people can't get over but you can't tell
a country how to conduct themselves you
know you can't tell them you know you
should be teaching this in your schools
not your country not your world
by what if they don't want to teach that
to children but they are okay with
college students like I don't know I
don't know anything about it so yeah
because in American history - they're
not teaching about all the [ __ ] up
[ __ ] America's doing no Rossi's they're
not doing that and they don't I think
it's it's state-specific cuz like people
in Georgia don't learn about Asian
American history oh yeah very true
literature Hawaii and California yeah
yeah there's there's there's a lot more
education on that
uh-huh but that's why people in Kansas
grow up thinking that we're all a bunch
of [ __ ] foreigners and not really
American enough yes no the contribution
contributions that we all made like as
are like as our family members everybody
like like all the the War veterans and
and people that contribute it to America
like and you know it's I feel like in
America too like one of the things is
like nationalism is so wishy-washy here
sometimes you know like I'm a hundred
percent for America right but if I ask
somebody what do you know about American
history right what do you know about
this country and its laws and politics
but you know it's it's sometimes it's a
farce I think it's because my history is
different from their history yeah yeah
cuz like if we have a bigger land - and
a lot more people it's hard to control
that [ __ ] you know like what just grew
up learning she grew up in Texas
right
so first off whatever political group
your state leans toward that's what the
education is gonna be yeah so if she's
Republic Republican state Texas and
Texas is very Texas centric they're
gonna talk about the Alamo they're
talking alot of Texas history and
they'll barely cover like the 13 states
or they don't they don't really care too
much about whatever happened in Boston
uh-huh but they'll cover a little bit of
it right
yeah then like you know my old roommate
Kevin he says when he grew up
they were so Boston pride and then the
the whole colonies and there's a lot of
State City pride type of exactly so
they're US history is gonna be centered
so much around local [ __ ] that like they
don't know about Cesar Chavez you know
they don't know about like yeah yeah
like that's that's that's true that's
dirt yeah so then when we grow up we
have a different idea of US history
yeah and I think that's where the
fighting comes yeah and it also goes
back to when we go back to that topic
like I think that's why for me I didn't
think about the whole Japanese Korean
thing yeah you know cuz I think I rep
Sacramento more than anything else like
Sacramento yes it's you know and it
sucks that people want me to care and be
a little more hateful about it and I
just like I love Japanese [ __ ] dude yeah
like first of all my girlfriend can read
and write and speak in Japanese yeah and
she's full-blooded Korean and she could
speak Korean read and write and I don't
see you guys as someone who is ashamed
of being Korean or hey I mean like you
specifically told me I want to marry a
Korean girl so I could continue the
culture speak the language stuff like
that yeah and I'm like you don't get
more prideful of your and have love for
your culture than that like I want to
continue it through having Korean
children yeah
speaking Korean language yeah you know
like like even if let's say I didn't
marry Barry yeah and let's say I married
no let's say a white girl my my
prerequisite is that that she learned
she has to notice between ya in vice
versa if she was like let's say she was
I don't know [ __ ] Middle Eastern
something right yeah she wanted me to
learn like Farsi or some [ __ ] yeah
I would do it I would I would do I would
[ __ ] take classes every night so I
could communicate to that family and be
respectful for that culture and I wanted
that same thing to be reciprocated back
to me and I couldn't find somebody that
would do it so there was you know a
couple of people that I dated and they
things were great that we vibe really
well but they didn't understand that
culture part they didn't understand why
it was important to me yeah and they
just said like I probably won't do it
I'm like then it's probably not gonna go
around them that's go more than that's
just you know fooling around so it
sucked and to me I never thought I would
end up with the Korean girl oh really I
never did I think probably dated about
two criminals my whole life
and that's about it and Muriel's one of
them so that was just a a weird thing
for me and I found out how important it
was for me to really preserve my culture
mm-hmm I didn't realize it man I didn't
realize how embedded it wasn't to me
yeah like how much I loved being a
Korean person yeah I mean that that that
tells me that you do have Korean pride
in a good way yeah not like the the
insecure way but at the same time it's
like it's like you don't need to be so
Korean to the point where you're you
don't want to be anything else you don't
care about any other culture and I'm not
trying to shove that [ __ ] in people's
face yeah you know like hey there's no
I'm Korean yeah like first of all dude I
just met you I have that's where my
Korean History Channel came from cuz we
would make fun of my friends who would
always preach Korea like the gospel and
I'm like okay but I heard enough yeah
you your uncle everybody can we just be
people yeah like to talk about like how
Korean invented this and that and that
I'm like this is funny but like can we
just talk about fishing or some [ __ ] you
know like man there's some people dude
there's people that I've met yo so when
I was when I went back to Sacramento I
met this dude in mind you he's a really
nice guy right and I wish some people
understood like time and place and
understand social context right you know
if I'm at a bar I'm chilling we're
drinking we're having a good time so
it's like that whole Dave Chapelle bit
where this dude came up right the whole
whole thing yeah what's up my brother so
I you know so he's trying to preach the
gospel to you or what gospel he was
talking about African his
three uh-huh that comes out what's up my
brother so just it he goes oh I'm
artists let me show you some of my art
real quick man just to put it out there
my brother you know we were actually
weren't called Africans that's something
that was a white construct that
Europeans across you were known as the
Moors I was like all right bro what's
your name let's start with that one like
it was so social context bro we're just
trying to chill mitt like you know that
would have been a great conversation in
a different setting yeah if I was in a
if you were a lecturing and I was in
school and I walked into African history
class yeah thank you very much cuz I
wanted that information where I enquired
about it or we were at a coffee shop or
something right bro
we're blasted drunk I'm not time and
[ __ ] place yeah and then I just sat
there I was like oh my god what is going
on yeah it was this whole thing like let
me tell you something with the white
people did it was you know like okay
like this is cool information man I
appreciate it is not the time and place
homey like chill
you know I just made everybody super
uncomfortable in the circle we just kind
of rely here and III dude nice to meet
you bro you know some we're [ __ ] man yos
funny my mom she was like so she was um
she was always like trying to get me to
have a girlfriend ever since like
preschool she was like I wish you bring
up girlfriend home like cuz she thinks
it's cute being in a relationship and
[ __ ] right yeah and then um she would
always be like Oh is she Korean like and
then I don't know why she wanted she I
think for one she thinks Korean girls
are pretty but she was like telling me
that one day she had a back in the day
she had a boyfriend that was Korean ooh
she had a secret he was a he was a he
was a Korean immigrant but like born in
Japan mmm and so and she came from a
prestigious family all right so like so
that's like a stain it's not only the
Korean part but because he wasn't it was
more so that the class part ah because
he wasn't a part of like like royalty
lineage exactly yeah so I'm pretty sure
if he was like the son of [ __ ] latte
or something is a different story yeah
yeah but yeah I mean like
Asian people for you right it's cuz he's
Korean no because he's poor yeah that's
more important yeah that's the whole
thing but they don't understand about
Asians it's like it's it sounds like the
race thing but what they're really
saying is like I want you to marry up in
class or the same class
yeah and so like whatever social
construct that was taught to them right
so my mom was like she was like yeah
like Koreans they're so emotional and
expressive and I loved him but like I
had to cut the relationship and then and
then so like she she was always
encouraging of like me making Korean
friends and he should wanted me to have
a Korean girlfriend and all this stuff
and then so I think she always looks
back because you know like my parents
split and I think she always looks back
and goes like [ __ ] you finally married
that Korean guy for love I know we would
have fought every day we would have
still been together would have been
passionate yeah yeah did you date a
Korean girl before yes I did how was
that like yeah you know what's [ __ ]
crazy
so like I I dated here and there but
like one girl that I actually had a
relationship with for a year right so
like I met her online through I think it
was a fine depicts no [ __ ] like we do
[ __ ] cute right yeah and then so we
were talking and after a week we
realized that as as children we met each
other because her family her
grandparents rented a house that my
uncle owned oh what the [ __ ]
yeah and when they came over to like
look at the house and play I was there
playing yeah so because their
grandparents recognize my face oh really
yeah and this is when I was like 19 or
18 oh wow
so yeah like they she showed him a
picture of me and all this stuff and
like and in and in so and my last name
you were gonna marry her at that point
you're like [ __ ] married now that's
[ __ ] fate that's a Korean drama story
I know and then I mean we got along well
and things like that but I think we were
both really immature at that age yeah
and she was a bit crazy for me
of course she's the girl that I told you
about where she was like she's like I
feel that you look like I love you more
than you love me so we can't be together
and intial yelled at me and she hung up
oh my god and ten minutes later she
called and she's like I'm sorry what the
[ __ ] dude and my purse saw you when
you're playing with the Duke you know
sandbox I thought you were the one
forever that's so great yeah wild man
you know if at a young person if I heard
that story and I was a part of that
story I'm not yeah we get a marry girl
that's it
cuz I would I was I wanted to yeah it is
it is kind of like what a coincidence I
know prior to me I used to live in a
small bubble Sacramento is a small
bubble and all I could think about was
after college or whatever becoming a
teacher I wanted to be an educator yeah
and then I wanted to have a house get
married and have a kid that's all I
thought about man that's all I ever
cared about and then I got dumped for
the first time and then it really opened
my eyes to how much of a [ __ ] I was
like you are such a [ __ ] loser dude
like the only thing that you could think
about right now is this girl yeah who is
this girl do you yeah who is she yes and
it took me after like maybe like a year
and a half because I was still trying to
get back with her for a year and a half
like a [ __ ] loser and then finally
something snapped in me dude I was I had
this moment where I was like dude what
are you doing you are making a fool of
yourself Wow what the [ __ ] are you doing
dude like I remember I was just fawning
for her attention so much and she looked
at me one day and she was like dude
you're really annoying and I was like
what do you mean I'm annoying so you
were too sprung weirdos bro you seemed
desperate and she lost interest yeah and
I just and I when she said that I went
home and I was like first of all it's
devastated you [ __ ] treacherous witch
and then I uh
I looked back and I looked at how I was
behaving and I was like holy [ __ ] I
don't have goals I don't think I want
you have to hold were you when you
recognize this I had to be what 19 no I
was 20 I'm sorry I was 20 21 and I was
like hold on a second dude what the [ __ ]
are you doing you 20 year old [ __ ] you
you're chasing after this girl for what
dude like who is she to you she doesn't
care about you she'd give a [ __ ] about
you bro you know you're you are annoying
David you're [ __ ] annoying man I
can't believe you were able to
self-reflect like that it would hit me
like a ton of [ __ ] bricks when she
says I mean that was my aha moment I
wish I had someone be that mean and
blunt to me I never had that I think it
took me a long while to recognize
because they would always be like oh
it's me not you hmm she'd be like oh I
just want to stay friends I just kind of
lost interest or whatever and the weird
thing that was happening was like she
was a type of girl to who I believe I'm
very sweet to the samp
I feel I still think she's a super sweet
girl and I was the piece of [ __ ] and
it's because she had that Savior complex
where she wanted to turn a turn into a
piece of God how was that turd for her
you know I was that [ __ ] turd and you
know in her case like I had very I'd at
that point I'd very low self-esteem yeah
you know and for me I found value in
what she found value in me
so she because she loved me you know I'm
worth something so when she broke up
with me I was like I'm not worth [ __ ] oh
man now it's like the opposite we have
girls that treat us or think of us as a
piece of [ __ ] we're really not yeah so
we need people to bring us down a
reality right because our ego just went
up here's the good thing so my ego my
ego was so crushed I was with her she
gave me so much value in my life that I
was when I wasn't trying to get back
with her I was trying to gain value
again by getting back with her and that
was the selfish part of it when I
realized how about how stupid that was
how much of a [ __ ] loser I was I I
try to change that immediately I was
like bro what are your goals you need to
have goals bro your goal can't be to
marry this girl with the white picket
fence ahead what kind of [ __ ] [ __ ] is
that and that was my biggest life lesson
huh for ever in the history that I've
ever lived yeah that was my biggest life
lesson and that was the biggest turning
point for me [ __ ] and that kind of set
is onslaught of me learning how to be a
hundred percent honest to be
unapologetically myself yeah no matter
what kind of flack you get and as a
comedian you need that - she's a good
catalyst she was she ruined me
great thanks - perfect she a shout out
to her for ruining me I wish I had
someone that mean
I'm annoying you it's too late man
I needed it when I was younger yeah but
that that was now it just hurts my
failings man you know she did some
fucked-up [ __ ] too you know yeah and at
the same time like I thanked her I hate
her and I think her because because of
that moment I turned out to be Who I am
today who was somebody who's still a
[ __ ] but at least I could take
responsibility for those fuck-ups yeah
yeah that's I mean that's what everyone
needs I think like I remember like I
would talk to like girls and I'd be like
oh just tell me what I did wrong and
[ __ ] and they won't tell me and I'm just
like [ __ ] now you have a girl who tells
you too much yeah I know I respect that
so much though I love you you [ __ ]
[ __ ] I know man I it's like I always
wanted someone that was straight up and
honest with me but now it's just too
much sometimes they lie to me please I
know respect that way [ __ ] more than
someone who beats around the bush yeah
and and and takes forever to get to the
point and I think I need to be told
straight I rest I respect that way more
man I feel like with you and Jess like
one of the things that I saw the most
was a big change in how you saw
affection and love because the person
that I saw you with before it was very
like I care about you when I feel like I
want to care about she was like that she
was like that too yeah it was off to you
know you guys had a very odd and off
relationship I think like if that person
came or went it didn't [ __ ] matter it
did it it's like you were here because
it's convenient and she's not about it
that way - yeah and so it was kind of I
was like is this Jonah understand what
love is is you know it's like sex
friends it was yeah that's what it was
and then when I saw what Jess was like
you didn't know how to deal with your
emotions very well cuz you didn't feel
this way it's like yo you're I [ __ ]
hate you but you're not going anywhere
you know that's like true love yeah
that's how I did was it was for her -
yeah for you - it was such a weird thing
that I was watching it was like I was
watching two people learning how to be
human you know I know like it's I mean
both of us avoided any type of what's
the word caught challenge challenge a
real challenge in a relationship writing
it's
from us both being abandoned we realized
that we have these walls real thick
walls and it's easier to leave and to
walk away with more pride and ego then
be vulnerable and open up and try to
work things out yeah both of us never
had a relationship that lasted over a
year
yeah if ever and whenever you know like
the infatuation is gone and things kind
of like chill out it's more like well
you're giving me problems and you're
annoying so [ __ ] you for some reason in
this situation we we can't like we can
hate each other from time to time but
like we just can't leave it can be yeah
it can be destructive but I think the
point is once we can get over that hump
yeah we start realizing that things can
be resolved yeah and it's like in the
past we just we just didn't resolve [ __ ]
it was like well [ __ ] you [ __ ] you okay
bye yeah now it's more like I'm sorry
yeah and that's that's that's the that's
the big part man like that was the big
part for me too because prior to me
getting with Mariel I didn't expect to
be with somebody in a serious
relationship
[ __ ] being in a serious relationship for
now I got career goals i'ma work on that
and then when I'm 30 I'll think about
getting that's just hiding yeah you're
just hiding from what you want in life
yeah and then when I met material
something clicked and I was like there's
something special about this girl I
don't know what it is yeah but I got to
figure this out first cuz I might regret
it later I was afraid of regretting it
cuz I saw somebody that I I was like yo
what is it about this chick you know I
mean that I like so much and then I was
flirting with her she ignored me for a
couple months and lo and behold you know
fast forward we'll get into that story
later when she's on this podcast but she
we ended up together and it was one of
the biggest I say positive mistakes I've
ever made in my life it always comes
when you don't expect it to because I
was just like i'ma [ __ ] around
yeah come to Texas for some [ __ ] your
best about it whatever but yeah I mean
and you learn a lot too from being in a
relationship and I you grow a lot
mentally emotionally everything and then
I think it's very important to have
someone that gives you pressure in in
good ways and bad ways yeah cuz like
when things are too easy
and things are too simple and not
challenging I get bored
yeah I'm that type like the girl that I
was dating like the the my Korean
girlfriend and when I was 18 like she
was emotional and crazy but at the same
time she was very easy in a way that I
didn't have to work for much and she
didn't piss me off so I don't know man
like it just felt like I got bored she
was a sweet awesome person that for most
of my life that's how I felt about a lot
of my relationships so I would just get
bored and then break it off what did it
make you feel like this man there's
something wrong with me like like
everybody is so sweet no I just feel
like I want new [ __ ] okay
like I I've been through that phase I
think I've been really burnt where like
I I've been in relationships where I
absolutely love this girl and then it
was puppy love maybe like 16 17 years
old
we would like like we would [ __ ] and all
this stuff and then like all of a sudden
this is what I hate about like that time
in age is a lot of people can't speak
their mind because they don't know
what's going on in their heart so don't
just people just like kind of not give
you an answer and break it off and I was
like for me i don't get closure yeah so
I'm obsessing over the fact that like
whether it was a lie or not how they
broke it off I'm so fixated on the words
of like like oh they said maybe we could
get back together in the future like you
know how like sometimes young girls
don't like confrontation yeah they'll
leave it kind of open and and and
they're more socially intelligent so
they're not straight up but they know
it's kind of a mean no but they don't
really say no you know I mean yeah
they're breaking up but then they want
to stay friends and it's kind of
confusing to a young guy yeah so me
being such a literal dude like I'm like
okay cool so it maybe in a month we
could try again yeah instead of just
accepting that it's over and moving on
yeah so like that made it really hard
for me where it's like four years
straight I'm just like waiting to get
back with that person like a loser oh do
I know what that feels because their
birthday and they're still they still
want to be friends because you know I
feel I felt like so weird like oh cool
we're gonna take a break we're gonna be
friends and then like and then I'm gonna
get back we're gonna get back together
like that's what I thought when I was 16
17 right yeah and I think a lot of dudes
go through that like like you know they
don't get a straight answer and then it
is a straight answer from the way she's
communicating but not how the guy
communicate because we don't want to
hear that dude we're like yang something
gonna happen later man and that's what
it was with me and the girl that broke
up with me yeah she was as a girl as a
home girl she was also like one of my
closest friends too yeah so I was trying
to salvage the relationship at the same
and I you know I try to separate my
feelings from her and I couldn't do it
because like I said I had value her
value to me was she gave me value to my
life and because I couldn't separate
those two there was no way and you know
I'll be real like that you know she was
nice you know the special about her
though like when I look back and I'm
like yo ho I dodged so many bullets man
the people I put on a pedestal back then
it was wow I had a low standard holy
crap I this is one girl I was really
wanting to marry yeah so you like I had
these feelings and I had these thoughts
previously but I think it was for the
wrong people and I wasn't ready for it
yeah so I shouldn't have expressed and
felt these feelings because I didn't I
didn't know how to deal with the map
yeah so afterwards it's like yeah I was
going through a hard time but I almost
felt like it's dangerous to give so much
of yourself to people yeah cuz yeah
they're not responsible meaning like
people are fickle do people are weak
like Bill
say like they love you but it's for a
week yeah you know and in and say you
give so much to them and then like
people who are damaged have that problem
right because they're used to
disappointment and failure and they
expect that out of other people exact it
happen so many times to them right so
when people bounce they go I knew you
were gonna leave I know you're gonna
bounce so you know who really [ __ ]
cares yeah and it's also easier to leave
them before they leave you yeah I I know
a lot of friends now who are going
through therapy yeah as an adult because
now that mental health is becoming
something that's important their
understanding you're like you know I'm
kind of [ __ ] up in the head
yeah and it's okay for you to say it too
cuz as a friend I couldn't say it to you
cuz then it seems like I'm not being
supportive of you right right so I came
up to my friend and let's say she was
I'll be it when I saw from outside
perspective I'm like but you got daddy
issues to the [ __ ] max but it's hard
to say that to them yeah I can't tell
them hey listen that people figure out
things on their own yeah like how do I
come up to where say hey man you [ __ ]
up you know you got to figure out your
[ __ ] problems you [ __ ] weirdo like
even if I said it in a nice way it
wouldn't come off that way because
that's how they would hear it yeah they
would hear it as if I'm judging them
yeah but when it comes from a impartial
party that you're paying for then it
becomes something like oh maybe this
person is saying something because it
feels unbiased yeah exactly
so I you know some people they say well
you should have said something now
because it wouldn't have come off that
way
yeah and we're friends with these people
and we know how they are as individuals
no matter what we would have said they
would have made the same mistakes and it
would have mean friends yeah it's like
if they want a family if they want long
a long-standing relationship they got to
figure those things out yeah cuz like
for me I can go two ways like I could be
single and live that dan Bilzerian life
til I'm dead yeah
and it's perfectly fine it's just a
lifestyle choice but if I want kids that
are gonna be same and if I want a
long-term relationship and a wholesome
family I can't I gotta figure it out I
got to figure out like what it is
that's making me battle myself you know
like everyone does and it's same for our
friends like that are going through
problems right like they gotta figure it
out if they want it
if they don't want to change or go
through the struggle they're not gonna
get it that's what I don't understand
yeah it's like you can't have both like
you think it's the other person every
time I talk to people it's the it's it's
always this like well if I find the
right person or the right guy then like
everything's gonna be easy [ __ ] no dude
yeah everyone's gonna give you annoying
problems everyone's annoying everyone
like like you could be the best of
friends you could no matter [ __ ] what
you're gonna fight yeah and then that's
when your ugly parts are gonna be it's
gonna come out man yeah man like my mom
said it the best this is what she said
to me she goes you know when I was going
through stuff with Mariel and I was like
yo this girl's pissing me off like I
don't know if this is gonna work like I
had a couple times in our relationship
right thought but maybe once or twice it
wasn't a lot or any point but my mom was
like you know ah David like give it some
time rest and think about it she goes
the problems that you say that are big
problems she goes don't pick problems at
all like you no matter who you're gonna
get with every girl's gonna give you the
same problem yeah every girl it's about
who do you think really helps build you
up there who stay with for the rest of
your life if that's what you want yeah
you know if you want the family and kids
this is not something that you're gonna
run away from there's no way that you're
going to just run away from this pop and
not expect to had the same thing happen
with another girl exactly going gonna
happen it happened so you have to
realize that this is within your realm
of controlling you yeah
so I I had to learn that the hard way
where I was like okay if she's acting
this way then I could intercept it this
way because it's not gonna happen like
so for example when she's on her period
I get mad because she's kind of mean to
me you know a little me yeah so does
that change the fact that I'm not gonna
have another girl who might be hormonal
and I'll be it'd be mean to me then I
just had to learn how to deal with that
yeah it's not to say that it's like
personality defect it might be another
problem it might be something else
yeah like she might be nice during her
period but she might be completely
disgustingly messy yeah it'll be
something it'll be yeah it'll be
something that'll piss you off
cuz it's not like I don't have qualities
that she hates that she has to deal with
- oh yeah you know it's all a balance
it's a give and take right and then can
you live with it yeah it's the most
challenging thing
ever and I think that's why everyone's
divorced it's not easy man like it's it
makes you look at yourself and you see
the ugliest side of who you are
yeah and then you have to fight yourself
you're really not fighting the other
person you're fighting yourself yeah
you're fighting your ability to stay
chill when you're being pushed yeah and
it's like can you can you accept that
can you put your own personal things
aside and cater to someone who's calling
you an [ __ ] literally right like like
joerger in trouble for nothing but you
also have to be nice to them 100% like
that's the hardest [ __ ] to do it's hard
to be nice to somebody when they're
being mean to you yeah and I and I and
I'm very adamant about this and I you
know I have a couple of friends that
I've helped out through this where I had
a friend who was I'll be it he didn't
really understand this concept and I was
trying to get him to understand
something he goes well you know she's
being a [ __ ] so imma be a [ __ ] [ __ ]
to her too you know she's in a bad mood
why the [ __ ] should I be in a good mood
it's like well listen to me man love is
love is something very interesting that
I think that I'm starting to learn too
I'm starting to learn that you cannot if
you want to be in a serious like
monogamous relationship you cannot
choose when to love and not love
somebody because it benefits you yeah
and that's I'm not saying it's easy
that's the hard part so sometimes we
have to say I love you and treat them
the best when they need it the most even
though it's hard for us that's the
hardest thing that and yeah like I said
I'm not saying this advice like it's
easy I'm trying to do this the most I'm
trying to do it the most what Mario
looks at me and she goes I [ __ ] hate
your sloppy estimate [ __ ] and I'm like I
understand you're in a bad mood maybe I
love you you think that's easy man yeah
you know I'm trying to I'm trying to
have it in Gladiator days where I will
kick her off a [ __ ] balcony man I
like you yeah [ __ ] yeah you know I
want to do that type of [ __ ] but I also
have to understand as she has to do this
for me too well she's in a bad mood
sometimes I think you ever loved the
most when it's not convenient for me and
that's the hard part man I think I think
I should have got with someone really
stupid because like the way I have
unconditional love for my dogs
yeah they can never piss me off yeah
I know that it's all impulse I know that
it's just it's like the way a baby like
I can't understand how some people get
so [ __ ] mad at kids like sometimes a
child it's a child like what what do you
expect no but then when I have respect
towards someone that's when they piss me
off
it's so weird because I expect more out
of them yeah so it's like I know you're
smarter than stru that is 100% actually
you help me with that a lot too because
you were like hey man you got these dumb
partners like just think of them as
idiots and expect those expected to help
me out a lot yeah cuz you know what's
gonna happen I was expecting the world
from them yeah not them like at an
individual and I couldn't it was dumb of
me I had to be smart about it's like you
know why are you expecting this idiot to
outperform you it's not going to happen
so what it's it's it's dumb of me to do
that yeah so it's true yeah we even we
have somebody we know to personally like
when I look at this girl she's very
sweet but goddamn she's dumb as bricks
and I had just look at her like you're
lucky you're very pretty
you know but she's like am I gonna get
mad at her because you know she says
stupid things there's no like she's just
dumb dude whatever she's okay with it
happy yeah it's like it's like a
six-year-old child you just look at them
as cute yeah you're like that's [ __ ]
cute and I wish I could have that type
of perspective when it comes to like my
relationship or something like but I
think because I put them on such a
pedestal yeah I expect so much more like
strength
discipline yeah like you know I and when
they when they don't react the way that
I know they're capable of reacting I
know personally disappointed and I get
so angry because I'm like man you're
getting pissed off over that [ __ ] or
like whatever you know yeah you and
that's what's hard for me managing your
expectations yeah that's a big part yeah
yeah that's not negative either - I
think don't don't think of managing your
expectations to be like oh well don't
have hope for anything that's not bad
that's not what it means yeah managing
your expectations being that you just
know what you're gonna get out of it
yeah just know it yeah you know know
that the two hundred thousand mile Honda
Element that you bought is going to
break down
and it's gonna cause problems the end
that the air condition is not gonna work
not a lot of people are not gonna know
how to fix it people are gonna call you
stupid and ugly for having that car and
you're gonna have a friend named Bart
that constantly makes fun of you
understand what you understand
what you get from what you bought and
that's what I'm learning and it's it's
like the forgiveness part I think like
there's a lot of great things that come
out of Christianity yeah the whole
concept of like forgiveness like true
forgiveness is like it's like really
being above it and whatever people are
acting like just know that a lot of it
is just impulse it's not directly
because of what you're going through
like sometimes you know people are just
irrational because they're in pain and I
found it odd you had like the the Korean
Christian parents that that were
hyper-religious yeah like [ __ ] Japanese
BJ oh man that's so anti-christian
there's a lot of hypocrite
like I mean even the Japanese Church I
went to man they're like they're so
Christian but they [ __ ] talk [ __ ]
behind each other's back
you know what it is it's its cultural
culture and religion mixing that's where
it becomes a pretty because the
unconditional love doesn't exist in
Asian culture a lot of them yeah so they
don't understand the concept it's not
ingrained in them yeah so I don't know I
don't know how I don't know yeah it's
interesting guys yeah man that that
concludes that part of the podcast Japan
versus Korea turned into love and
relationships yeah man and that's that's
what I wanna this one want to [ __ ]
nail into people men start to start
understanding people I have empathy
towards people yeah it helps it helps a
lot yeah he does
it does yeah well guys we'll see you
next time stay beautiful out there shave
your poop poop oops your poops
that's a poops poops or get it lasered
yeah get it later so it doesn't come out
let it grow naturally and braid it
that's right brush your teeth and be
happy have a good time Matta people
peace